savait que américain est en particulier
oui c'est un jeune homme qui a décidé de
poursuivre ses parents en justice
mais pour une raison assez surprenante
l'homme âgé de 40 ans demande à ses
parents 86 mille dollars de
dédommagements pour avoir détruit ses
quatorze cartons de magazines films et
joué porno un combat un peu vain alors
que quasiment tout est disponible sur
internet
bon alors le litige a commencé en 2016
quand le jeune homme est retourné vivre
avec ses parents après son divorce il
était seul il s'est dit je vais
retrouver ma petite collection de
jeunesse je n'ai et puis finalement tout
avait été foutu à la poubelle donc la
valeur de l'ensemble des biens
s'élèverait à près de 29 mille dollars
dit-il
et donc il réclame à ses parents pour le
préjudice coccyx be à 86 1822 dollars
qu'est ce qu'on en pense de cette petite
histoire damien tient bon écoutez moi je
trouve que les parents ont eu raison de
se débarrasser de sa collection parce
que la pornographie et instaure un
certain mal ça arrive un certain malaise
à la maison c'est à dire que on est
tenté on a envie de les regarder bref je
trouve que la pornographie entache
l'esprit donc à part une bonne idée
d'attaquer ses parents juste si je
trouve au contraire c'est une preuve
d'amour que les parents au fait
vis-à-vis de son enfant lui disant
écoute passe à autre chose vraiment à
c'est quand même un adulte qui revient à
la maison il a grandi avait débarrassé
de la chambre d'enfant pas d'anneau
voilà maintenant mêlée par les parents
et n'ont pas retiré ses cartons et l'a40
en effet ce qu'il veut ce mec il les
prend avec lui surtout j'ai gagné mon
sérieux mais non mais faut mais
pardonnez moi mais à aucun moment ça
vous gêne contre les pas ça vous gêne
pas contre les les parents et et le ce
jeune homme qui maintenant à 40 ans on
parle de dammarie les lys un porno qu'on
avait à la maison avec les parents faire
moi c'est pas gênant tout est bien des
bars et dans la famille les parents ils
sont barrées d'aller fouiller dans les
jambes du gosse de prendre les pornos
l'autre il est barré d'aller prendre du
porno pour les récupérer il est encore
plus barré d'aller faire procès à ses
parents ils sont barrés les familles
il va perdre le procès parce que il va
pouvoir tout ré enregistrer ce qu'il a
perdu sauf une vidéo qui s'appelle les
grosses mais me chante je pense que
l'agent michel herr a poussé people je
les ai tous les belges ou des données
tous les départs jeter ses déchets
récupérables sur internet sauf les
grosses mais méchante voilà d'accord et
je ne sais pas ce qu'il ya dans ce fait
de nature nous que tu l'as pas vu ses
films sur le mais je demande à jean
pierre peut être qu'il avait solidarité
[Applaudissements]
je vois que vous avez de seine hauts de
seine
occupation la maison avec des pierres
ils voient bien sympa pardon pas que
nous sommes des frères et c'est
exactement ça vous à la maison il n'y a
pas de norme allemande on écoute et on
n'est jamais à l'abri redoublement de
quelques surprises ce jeune homme est
très mal élevé j'en veux à ses parents
pourquoi il est très mal élevé osé
réclamer de l'argent que si ça se trouve
il a tapé en plus dans le porte monnaie
oui pour amener à l'époque elle va
acheter ces trucs à l'époque mois là à
leur place je retournerai le procès face
à lui c'est moi qu'il poursuivrait ce
tir des mauvaises ouais je le
poursuivrai pour diffamation pour plein
de choses
j'invente ray toute une ville mais je
lui donnerai surtout une bonne fessée
danse et kankan ludivine est en colère
elle donne des bonnes fessées à
l'occupant
[Applaudissements]
téléspectateurs le garçon qui te suit
par an pour avoir détruit ce qu'ils
t'ont grattée je comprends où je ne
comprends pas vous avez vous ne
compreniez pas à 85% en plus comme
évidemment nathalie a fait une enquête
il ne reste donc plus que quoique grosse
méchante arrivée méchante oui ça va ça
se trouve çà et là
ses parents avaient déjà détruit à sa
collection de jeux vidéo par itil
[Musique]
ce qui l'avait fait avant lui n'ont quoi
il a peut-être qu'il a peut-être si
quelque chose de grave mais vous alors
vous serez la manière forte voile vous
prenez les gens qui doivent être
détruits mais qu'ils détruisaient comme
samba ouais mais je suis sûr qu'en tout
cas il reconnaîtra pas la même erreur
c'est à la maison chez les rhétoriciens
field il y en a pas un qui moufte